I'm Grandmaster Brian Smith we're here
was analyze this and we're seeing the
game between player named Randy Bradshaw
and Arjun and Randy Brad shall start off
with E for Arjun and played a five okay
so far a good night f3 knight c6 d4 so
why it went for a scotch game he takes
d4 and c3 so this is a scotch gambit
which is not really a very popular
opening but I'm all mostly because black
has can take the pawn or bike and give
them or refuse the gambit and get a good
game so it's more common to take this
pawn back with the knight or play Bishop
c4 also a move
okay so c3 he played and now black black
play-doh is surprising move here this is
a very open game so you need to develop
your pieces quickly black played Knight
to e7 Knight G to e7 and this this it
looks like too risky blocking the
development and yeah he doesn't want to
play Knight f6 because why'd you play
knight Knight G to e7 well yeah that's a
good point
Knight of 65 would attack the knight but
there are other possible moves so
there's a reason not to play Knight f6
but it's not really a reason to play
Knight to e7 because this move is to
slower development and if you're not
careful your wife would get a strong
attack and at least gets the pawn bag
one thing black could do would be this
move if you want to play it safe and not
take the pawn you can play this because
after takes Queen takes and avoid takes
the pawn back black it's easy
development Knight f6 and if white snake
goes sir White's Knight goes there what
do you think black would do
any ideas pin it yeah you don't want to
move the Queen because then d5 would
come it's really important in open
positions to get your pieces out as fast
as possible
so that's one way that you can decline
the gambit you can also capture the pawn
and then there's different ways you can
play like Bishop before I guess d6 I
don't know this opening very well but
it's not supposed to be - yeah white
that's what white sacrificed the pawn
white gained a lead in development but
black has a pond so it's you know and
black should be able to to take this
pawn and survive it's been played lots
of times
but if you if you don't want to deal
with White's initiative which could be
dangerous maybe but you know it's not
it's a more practical problem than a
real problem you can play this which is
what another reason why this opening
isn't so popular because I mean black
just destroys white center and equalizes
real quickly this way and if white
pushes pawn by then taking on c3 and I
mean now the center is closed so and
there's no there's nothing on this a2 to
g8 diagonal so that's that's good for
black but Knight to e7 mmm it's too slow
development I think now White's why just
played this move and I don't like this
move because the bishop is bishops
pretty passive there I mean it's better
to and it allows black to play d5 easily
it's better to to bring it to this if
you want to leap keep offering the pawn
to bring you to this diagonal now
they're ideas like Queen to b3 coming
you know or 95 in a g5 in some cases and
also just taking the pawn back and waits
ready to Castle as well so this this
looks pretty dangerous for black I think
of say black goes night there and how he
just take the pawn back and black
doesn't have this doesn't have a counter
attack in the center with d5 so White's
got a strong pawns and they're in this
night maybe not so
so well placed on g6 and so it looks
pretty good for white but if black takes
the pawn then probably something like
Queen to b3 attacking f7 threatening
checkmate that looks dangerous
or wait could just take the pawn back as
well and continue it like a gambit so
but Bishop d3 it's a little bit passive
and now a a kind of strange move I think
g6 because again I mean it does it's not
too bad just after Bishop d3 but I would
rather since white played this passive
move I think you can just continue with
your plan take the on and then Knight to
g6 and get ready to develop and castle
and blacks and black has white doesn't
have enough compensation for the pawn
okay so g6
why decided now to take the pawn back
another thing black could do is d5 to
just this is a move I want to play as
black because it clears out the center
and it gets rid of white space advantage
okay so g6 so he wants to fianchetto is
bishop now white took the pond okay d5
this is a very good move
d5 just the this this move d5 is very
good move okay argent very good because
this this counters his strong center and
it forces him to either advance and
block things up and also leave this pawn
on d4 behind or lets you capture at some
point and then put pressure on isolated
pawn on d4 so I decided to advance which
looks natural but pawn on d4 is really
going to be kind of I mean also white
structure doesn't isn't too threatening
so maybe white should consider just
playing Knight to c3 for instance and
then after takes Knight takes they're
aiming it at f6 and then after this
maybe I can develop quickly like that
and try to he got he's got a weak pawn
on d4 it's true but he's aiming at f6
and
he's got so you know but I can even take
that point but then there's gonna be a
check on f6 and black is gonna be have
to give up to Bishop so okay but I can
Castle there he also could play Bishop
g7 again here okay so why play d5 and
now
okay e5 Bishop g7 and I think Bishop g5
is it asking a little too much of the
position here we don't know where the
bishop is gonna be best
probably night and probably better to
just bring the Knight to c3 or even you
know what else this pawn to d4 has been
left behind
so black might be putting a big pressure
on it by Bishop g4 pinning the night and
it might be a good idea to just stop the
pin by playing h3 so we're just castle
and then yeah okay so so black so white
played Bishop g5 and black castle in
White Castle and here h6 so ours and
wise you play h6 alright okay but if you
you threaten the bishop but is he gonna
overlook the bishop being threatened
because he gonna leave your believe the
desert was there any I mean your
opponent I don't know he's nine hundred
or something but still do you think
there's any chance he wouldn't do like
Knight c3 no so then you have to ask
yourself I threatened his Bishop okay
he's gonna move the bishop away but does
this move actually helped me and I don't
think it really does because I think it
weakens our King just like after this
move which he played I don't think g5
really helps you that much he also could
just go somewhere else
like to e3 or something like that and
this move opens the king a little bit
then later on maybe he'll attack upon
with queen of d2 and gain a move also
pushing f6 later on might be a little
harder to do so i'm not sure about i
think that i mean it's not too bad but
in general you don't want to do it i
move just to threaten one of your
opponent's pieces only if it helps you
when they make the best movie in reply
so I'm thinking this what
as he do after this flex threatening do
you see what blacks threatening what's
blog threatening
yeah he's pinning the night but what's
the threatening to do yeah Knight takes
d4 now he might not I mean he might see
that too he probably will right but then
the thing is even if he sees that he has
two ways to move guarding that pawn
right he has to either retreat his
Bishop here or maybe maybe go with his
bishop back here but one way or another
you get it develop your bishop and he
has to retreat and guard that pawn and
all and in general you want to put
pressure on this pawn over there after
this now maybe you could unpin your own
night and you're and you're ready to go
Knight a5 for instance and put even more
pressure on that there's different
things black could do okay you went h6
because you wanted to chase this bishop
away which it is natural but I think
that chasing the bishop away kind of
opens up your own King so he decided to
go here and then you went g5 which also
you might regret that now but he was
provoked here and he went in sacrificed
a piece and now it started to get real
interesting sometimes someone doesn't
move like this and it allows a person to
sacrifice for two pawns and opens up the
King is it good or not but it all it
always depends on you got to look ahead
and see is white gonna be able bring up
a new enough attacker see in this case I
don't think white had enough attackers
so he should I think instead after g5
just probably move the bishop here now
the these moves might black might end up
regretting this because maybe white will
attack with H for some time or you know
various other things
oh I can use two because these pawns can
go backward so I think that's I think
that well it's not terrible I mean maybe
you can do this or something like that
buts
I think that you're gonna like those
pawns pushed forward on your Kings side
it's gonna be a long term you know
probably okay so so he so so he went and
took the and took the pawn though so g5
he took with the night okay black took
back good Bishop takes and now you made
a very good move you went f6 so white it
looks like a very scary attack White's
going Queen h5 and then check me on h7
all right and there's a pin on this
night so black can't easily go Bishop of
5-2 to oppose the bishop and also even
if this didn't work somehow
why would also have a back-up plan of f4
f5 f6 that type of thing advancing the
pawn and then this Knight can also come
in 92 Knight f3 and so on so it looks
very scary but once black creates some
defensive lines and gets his pieces over
then and also breaks this pin it's sorry
it's changes completely and it's a
different situation so he took on f6
what would you do if white went Queen h5
did you see that move what would you do
after that
because what happened does anyone see
what happens if black takes the bishop
what is white to here now clean each
seven King f7 and the King runs away hmm
bishop g6 what can what can happen if a
bishop g6 yeah and hey it takes now
white could go back with Queen h5 and
maybe King e6 but it the in any case
white doesn't win for sure okay maybe
the demon king after Queenie try of King
e6 I think black is safe cuz he can
block with a knight on f5 if the Queen
goes to g4 but there's a better move
here we don't need to go looking so when
you got this position on the board let's
say you have a white pieces and you got
this position on the board and you're
thinking what to do do you jump in the
Queen h7 and start trying to look 10
moves ahead to see if you win because
that's not the only move cleaning it
Queen h7 there's another move here see a
good move for a white
well Queen g5 that's not really where we
want the Queen and also now black could
black could do this and offer a trade Oh
Queens you have Bishop h7 now this so if
you've seen this pattern next time it's
gonna be a lot easier to find it bishop
h7 instead of the Queen check we checked
with the bishop which doesn't look as
dangerous but the problem is that King
can't get away right so King has to go
where where can the King go it has to go
to h8 and now how do we win bishop g6
check so we've moved our bishop to get
to the g6 square but I can't take it
because he's in check Bishop h6 doesn't
do any good because the Queen takes
right so black has to go to g8 and then
Queen to h7 right so now that you've
seen this pattern you should be able to
see Bishop h6 much quicker but if you
haven't seen it before it's a little
harder because your first impulse is to
check with the Queen but then again also
when you're playing chess just because a
move seems obvious at first doesn't mean
you should start just jump into it and
start thinking trying to think five
moves ahead and trying to figure out
because there might be another move
which is which would be you know
completely obvious once you see it that
it's the right move you know so so
anyway but what should black do he can't
take the bishop so what should black do
after Queen after a queen h5
if white played queen h5 yeah Bishop f5
very good you got to neutralize this
bishop from d3 and that's and then
that's gonna be like the game okay so
instead of Queen h5 which I suspect
white would have played if we saw it he
took on f6 it doesn't make much
difference now as long as black finds
the best offense he takes f6 Bishop
takes f6 now Queen h-have white really
has to do something to to you know get
some attack going because White's down a
piece for two pawns and that's really
only one point of material but it's more
than that because if white doesn't get
something going blacks couldn't even use
the open files on the Kings side not
only up in material well we'll use the
open files on the Kings side to start an
attack Plus this pawn on d4 is a is
isolated and weak so Queen h5 okay now
Arjen played a move which wasn't quite
the best what do you think black should
do here
Bishop f5 yeah I mean this this move and
now the the key is to get rid of that
that Bishop that's on d3 which is a
strong attacker so I don't see anything
for white here really Bishop takes
Knight takes Queen g6 check in a g7 and
there's no way through d4 is falling why
it's just pieces are just getting traded
off so he so so you actually played
Knight f5 which just I can might not be
bad either but it might it looks like
now White has at least a draw okay in
fact yes Queen g6 check right now the
difference is 97 doesn't work right what
does black do or what is white do rather
any ideas or at least it looks really
dangerous in fact it it actually just
it's too dangerous to play this I think
what could wait to hear
the difference compared to the other one
is these two bishops right so now white
still has a bishop on d3 which means he
can check and now we didn't have that
same thing as before there was no Queen
wasn't on h5 but anyway so King f7 right
and now I suppose Bishop to g6 I mean
white has at least a draw here and
probably way more Bishop to g6 what if
the King goes here would his way to now
anyone see take the knight because that
bishops pinned so black has to run up
here and he's really running the
gauntlet here now we're running though
whatever now King e6 rook e1 check for
instance I don't know there's there's
lots of different moves but look at the
King running around there I think that
black definitely I mean for instance
King here we got check right and if the
King goes here we got this check and
then strong be checkmate
if black puts a piece on e5 I will take
it so that's that's so so that means
that black can't block so he went King
h8 which is right okay but now I made a
mistake he said okay I can take this
Knight
so anyway but listen but the difference
here is that these bishops were not
traded so what's the lesson we learned
when you're defending you want to try to
trade off attacking pieces so when we
had it when Arjun had the choice of two
ways to stop Queen h7 here okay Bishop
f5 or Knight f5 bishop if I bringing out
a new piece and trading off stuff was
better than Knight of 5 which left white
with a strong attacker versus the bishop
on c8 which is which is sitting at home
so in just in principle Bishop f5 would
be the NAT and the normal the natural
move the knight of 5 clean g6 King h8 he
played the right move and now white
decided to try to take his piece back
but he didn't see something he missed
something tactical he saw that two
pieces are attacking this Knight Bishop
on d3 and the Queen on g6 all
this Bishop is guarding it however he
didn't see that this is all whites
bishop on g5 is also under attack so he
probably confused himself with the
tactics and thought what Bishop takes
Bishop takes Queen takes but then Bishop
takes g5
so what whites should have done is just
gone here and make a draw
okay because if the King goes back here
okay and he's he's down a piece so he
should take a draw and if the King goes
up here anyone see what this would be a
mistake anyone see what white would do
Bishop h6 yeah and where and if black
takes Queen g6 and queen h7 right and
and if the King goes back somewhere like
here then what
we could take the rook right just simply
take the rook and now this is under
attack - so we're gonna win a piece okay
I mean white wins a whole rook actually
and was down at peaceful whites and also
whites off to pawns and exchange and of
course you can't go to the age file
because why it'll just take that rook
for free okay so so that so black would
have to go back to g8 and then and then
check and it should be a white white
should make a draw but instead now he
either didn't see that or he missed he
thought he could do better so he took
here and now black took back very good
okay because checkmate on h7 otherwise
and now Queen takes but now Bishop takes
and still it looks scary blacks king is
wide open right however the white only
has the Queen and black has lots of
pieces to come up there and defend and
you may think okay it's only a little
material advantage one pawn essentially
White's up you got two pawns for the
piece however this is totally lost for a
white I would say and maybe practical
game it's I mean it's it's a really if
black plays right is totally lost for
white because there's just no way to
bring up new attackers if black is
careful blacks gonna also have a target
here and he's gonna bring his pieces
over to the King side and start
attacking white they're gonna bring us
get just cleanup bring his rooks over
and put them on the F energy files and
start aiming at White's thing and he has
an extra piece to do it also so that's
so that's really bad for white okay so
he played Queen h3 check this is rook
cleaners under attack
King g7 that's good okay getting the
King up there and now queen g4 and here
Arjen allowed white some chance he made
a kinda strange move King f7 he wanted
to get out of this pin but the king is
not very safe over there in the middle
like that it's not it's not terrible
because white white still stands much
worse but do you see a good way I mean
white plans to play h4 or f4 or
something to attack the bishop which is
pinned what do you see that black could
do though here anyone see a strong
active move that would gain time and
soft White's plans
rook f4 yeah so this move this move
looks real good for black I mean black
it's the rookie in with gain of time and
now there's you know now there's nothing
happening maybe Queen here or even just
take the pawn which also you see what
that threatens was that threaten Arjun
Knight to e2 and then black just takes
over the game here so rook f4 is
practically just two deadly move you
know it's gonna be white that's gonna be
under attack in a moment and down a
piece but okay so King of seven oops
now f4 okay so White's trying what he
can Bishop h6 okay whatever and he may
be well okay Bishop h6 personally I
would rather have the Bishop on f6 where
it's aimed at t4 but I don't know maybe
White has a draw like this no can come
back to g8 and then block with the
Bishop white checks again block with a
bishop and if white checks here then
rook f7 and here blacks king is all
covered and this pawn is gonna fall so
that looks that looks pretty I mean I
would rather have the Bishop on f6 then
on h6 okay so Bishop h6 that we went to
queen h5 okay King g7 and now because
black lost a little bit of time white
gets the rook in okay but still very
good for black rook f3 threatening rook
g3 and then this Bishop would like if
white could move again it would be rook
g3 King h7 queen g6 check so Hodgins saw
that and anticipated it with King age 7
okay rook g3 threatening Queen g6 again
and Queen f6 so very good all out of
defenders around the black king if flex
careful white shouldn't win shouldn't
have anything at all finally white
developed this Knight okay Queen a d4
check King h1 and here in I know that
like this is a winning position for
black but in a practical game it's kind
of tricky because your kings open and
there's you know is I don't know I've
seen lots of games versus
someone might screw up in a situation
like this especially white wants to
bring the night white has a plan to
bring the Knight to g5 the black king is
kind of cut off on the G file here white
has a plan to go night of three and a g5
check and it's varied looks very
dangerous and you can it's easily it's
easy when you're playing the game to
start your head starts spinning and
everything but it's best to keep keep
calm and say okay he wants to bring the
knight there I remove its support and
after so after king each one just Queen
takes f4 and what is white half here
what can we do the Knights under attack
here well okay but rook to d1 first of
all I mean what am I afraid of and I
well then there might yeah I'm I can
take on d2 because queen g6 chuckin h8
and still nothing here right so that's
and that's what would the same thing if
white did that right away Queen jisuk
well there's a made on f1 rook takes
Queen takes d2 is a good because made
native white if white takes it as
typical rook takes T to look careful one
and and so in also Queen g6 immediately
doesn't do anything Knight f3 now I
suppose
look now
maybe now rook to GA
and what does the way have so ok so
instead white white went oops English 1a
night of network g8 Knight f3 and now
it's real important that you be watching
what whites playing is planning Knight
g5 check is also playing rookie 1 so so
can you take on f4 though I saw I still
don't see exactly what White's doing
here it looks a little bit a little bit
scary but what's white what's White's
plan what's white gonna do now G 5 you
take it right so it's real it was real
important to get that pawn queen takes
p2 I think was probably this was a real
big mistake and maybe it should lose the
game because now the Queen's too far
away and suddenly rook e1 and now this
rook is about to come up to e6 and
there's so many attackers around the
black king so it was big difference to
get the Queen over there and get the
pieces around the kingdom okay rook e1
now black took on g3 H takes g3 and I
don't know if what defense black has I
don't I don't know how you can defend
this position because now white king is
totally safe there's no more targets and
there's no way that I can see to bring
up defenders really like if black O's
Queen f6 do you see a good move for
white here anyone see a good move for
white yeah rookie six this is a real
strong move because if Queen takes and
what
Nagi five good nice tactic and so glyn
black you know i mean queen there but
then then comes Knight g5 check and then
rook takes h6 and black is busted so so
in Queen to g7 right away then
again I suppose Ricki six and I don't
know how black can stop night because
this bishop is real bad here it's
talking and now Knight to g5 is coming
so at Queen takes g3 doesn't doesn't
help because h6 is hanging for one King
anyways better is even better it would
be to probably even better as is this
forcing made quickly or that black has
to go up to clean okay so so rook e1
black played King g7 and work e6 now
there's only now there's there's only
one one thing I can see that black and
try do you see one problem with white
white position anyone see I mean it
looks terrifying for a black h6 is
hanging there's nowhere for this Bishop
to go Arjun played rookie J which is a
natural move but then comes checkmate
into whoops this one so this was it this
was pretty I think it was pretty
instructive game cuz there's there's a
lot of points where there's a lot of
games where where somebody might
sacrifice a piece for two pawns and it's
not really sound but someone but it
seems like so dangerous the key is you
know first of all get your pieces over
to defend and trade off the attackers so
you can see you can see that this in
this game sorry a little bit sick okay I
thought well we have about 18 minutes
left I thought I'd show you it's not
maybe quite long enough but I'll show
you a little bit faster version some
some game I play which is kind of
entertaining this is a blitz cam which I
played a long time ago okay
so I played efore this was just it was
in a tournament it was a torn it splits
tournament but I have a long long time
ago so I
yeah this is a Sicilian defense and I
played I was white I played the open
Sicilian okay
and he played in I Dorf this is an ID or
anyone know what this you so that is
okay if I if I if black wants to play e5
if he does it right away it allows this
check and this is kind of a problem
because if black trades off the bishops
then then this square here on d5 it
doesn't have very many defenders blacks
left with this Bishop there okay
meanwhile if the knight blocks then
comes Knight a5 and this pawn is under
attack and also the knight can later on
retreat there and try to use this
outpost square so a6 it was invented in
the middle of the 20th century around
some time 40s I guess first of all it's
kind of a waiting move but second of all
after Bishop e2 black can now play e5
and and then he he has this hole but he
gains a lot of space and gains time in
the Knights not so well placed on b3 so
that's the night but I played now Bishop
c4 and here black shouldn't really play
e5 most likely because the bishops aimed
at d5 square so he played this and I
went here anticipating a possible attack
on the bishop so black might go here
this is one of the moves he chose to
just play that and because this move is
a little bit quieter I I can be it
doesn't put pressure on the center I can
play this but you see what the idea of
this is looks kind of crazy right what
do you think
yeah I want to attack the night so for
one thing when black castles you have
black castles that's gonna provide
chances for an attack but it's not just
that it's also that I'm chasing this
night away from guarding key Square D 5
and from attacking the pawn on e4
so black might stop the pawn from
advancing
but then is he gonna want a castle later
that's it's gonna make it very hard for
him to castle because it's some I'm
gonna Castle queenside that's for sure I
probably played I forgot I've had this
several times but I'll probably play
something like I either I think I played
different things in different games
Queen e2 and maybe Bishop e3 I don't
know but I'm gonna Castle queenside but
this move h6 makes it real hard from to
Castle kingside because then I can play
H I can play g5 and open files instantly
because it'll come into contact with
this pawn on h6 mm-hmm yeah I'll leave
the rook of course on h1 I might play h4
and then g5 I might play g5 straight
away but in any case it would be
dangerous for the King to be over there
so H but aged six still black leaves the
king in the center but it keeps the
knight on f6 so that's and if he doesn't
castle it's not easy for me to go g5
because I'll have my own weaknesses then
but he didn't go h6 he played a little
bit of risky move he castle so he
castles into the attack but he hopes to
okay the king will be safe for enough
time that a counter-attack will happen
in the mist rest of the board
c5 97 and now I I think I played rook g1
first I don't know if it's clean okay I
stay up late Queen h5 I played those two
moves and it doesn't really matter the
order but anyway Queen age 5 so I'm
bringing my queen out I'm gonna maybe
Castle queenside okay he played b5 so he
wants to bring the bishop here his ideal
thing to have happen would be Bishop d7
b 4 and then Bishop takes e4 which will
defend h7 pawn then he'll have a solid
defender Bishop on g6 later on so he's
putting pressure on my e4 two different
ways one directly by Bishop e7 and
one indirectly by trying to attack the
knight which guards it I really have to
hurry here because if my Center
collapses my I won't get anywhere with
my attack on the Kings side and I'll
have a bad position
what is pretty dangerous attack so how
would you continue here oh my gosh yeah
I did actually kind of tell you okay
rook to g1 so the idea is I'm gonna lift
my rook up and over it's it's real
caveman-like but that's what this
position calls for yeah I mean there's
another way to play h4 h5 and g6 to try
to attack there but it's too slow I
think here may be possible I don't know
but but okay b5 rook g1 now he went
before so he's asking is my knight gonna
where's my knight gonna go so what
should I do what do you think this is a
real sharp position he's hoping my
knight moves
wherever okay oops then he goes Bishop
they're attacking the pawn now I have to
waste time with this move and now maybe
he he starts getting in d5 maybe even
right away or maybe maybe Knight here
first and now there's threats against
this pawn in some cases and d5 coming up
blowing open the center and am I gonna
get a chance to checkmate him in that
case I'm gonna be dealing with stuff
happening against my own King right away
so in the 10th key is a counter attack
in the center is important so I have to
be really forceful here so I played the
move rook g3 I ignored the knight now
remember this is a blitz game so I'm
kind of just going by intuition you have
five minutes per side so most a lot of I
calculated lines of course but it's
mostly going by intuition so for
instance if he takes here I need to just
I mean I need to show why I'm able to do
this so what do you think why it would
do now I need to destroy the Kings side
somehow and get my attack going and it
has to be a big attack because I'm down
a piece
I Rock h3 is natural move it it
threatens there but then he goes here
and in a folks and then if takes now
this move push the pawn okay but he he's
very happy that pawn is there as is
often the case and now my piece are
being forced backing him down a piece
and I got nowhere but think about this
position this would be crushing if he
didn't have an f7 pawn there so that's
why I would have made a preliminary
sacrifice Knight takes right and then if
pawn takes a check King there and now I
do this okay so he has to play h6
there's no other way to stop mate
because after night there I just take it
so he has to play each six but now what
do I do
what do you think
very good queen g6 I don't want to take
this pawn because you see what black
would do yeah he pushes pawn right and
now I can't get in I can't get into the
Kings side I could go here but he could
uh he could defend like like this or
something there's something like like
that and and now White's not gonna get
anywhere I'm not gonna be able to
checkmate him and I'm down too much my
position collapsing everywhere to pieces
down so but after Queen g6 Black has no
defense I'm threatening what you see
what I'm threatening I'm certainly
actually a couple of things but rookie
ch6 is the most immediate threat cuz
it's the most forcing and after he takes
I'll take with my queen and checkmate
I'm also threatening of course to take
with the pawn well which also be
crushing but I mean like if Knight to e5
and then this is crucial takes takes
checkmate and if he takes here then this
move and and now again the Queen can't
take because it's pin I would just win
to clean that way so that's what would
happen if he if he took the night I'm
gonna skip what would happen if if he
went Queen a5 because that's another
story but basically I I take the rook
and he just discovered check and makes a
second Queen but then I checkmate Queen
f7 Queen GA we don't have as much time
left so he didn't take the knight he
played this move which is it was like mm
you know he quickly plays move just an
intuition clearing the f8 square for his
knight and if his no gets to f8 I'm
gonna have problems because I can't I
mean maybe I want that problems but at
least my attack won't be getting through
so now rook each three-night f8 nothing
nothing going through with that Knight
on FA it's a great defender so what I
did was the same sacrifice Knight takes
c6 this is real typical sacrifice in
Sicilian black has to take tonight
because if Queen moves for somewhere
then for instance Knight takes g7 is
crushing breaking a bringing on Queen to
f7 threat into
into it so he took the night Bishop
takes now King can't go this way because
of mate right so King goes there and now
does anyone see what I might do here
here crew keeps three night f8 doesn't
get anywhere
so because the rook is on e8 so it's not
the same as the last position Queen h7
okay but I have to look ahead because
it's it's not as simple as it seems this
is a really natural sacrifice though but
it's what's funny is that of course it
doesn't have the normal kind of
follow-up which you would expect but
whenever you have the King cut off in
the corner like this
rook ready to come over this move should
be learning these kind of patterns is
key to becoming good chess player but
here you have to it's more than just the
obvious now what is way to yeah I
pushing the pawn looks normal looks
natural but now what
but now black has the smooth White's
down it too much
there's no follow up here so that's not
what I had you know I had to see this
from the beginning what I was gonna be
doing now mm-hmm yeah of course white us
to continue with tempo has to continue
with forcing moves
okay black has only go there right now
yeah it's easy to calculate this because
if with white pauses in most positions
it's gonna be black will have a chance
to defend yeah that's the only place to
go with the King know what g6 okay now
he can't go back here because I'm eight
okay Jade right and he can't go here
because oops we can't go to GA because
you see what should be six King f8 and
how again rotate chain right so he has
to go up to f6 now what do you think
pretty natural mode right thanks man
90 to d5 and bring that night into this
juicy central square but here's the key
point
and we're chasing the king well Black
has no pieces out basically before we
had to keep going or else maybe they
could bring some defender you could
bring some defenders over but here you
know you got to remember when you're
tasting like how does white continue
here as I gonna finish this up
okay bishop before he keeps running
which is gonna escape somehow over here
to b5 and go back into some corner over
here on b7 and then win so sometimes
when you're chasing your pawns King you
don't want to let him uh sometimes you
need to just not blindly chase him but
you need to cut off the escape instead
yeah rook d3 is good that's not what I
play but it's even you could say better
because this cuts the King off and
forces
next is f4 no or Bishop f4 and if black
goes here then f4 takes checkmate okay
the way I did it was c3 which takes a
move longer because after black takes I
take back and that's extra move but it's
still the same thing right Bishop g5 f4
and then here she resigned because if
takes Bishop takes and there's no other
defense now Bishop e3 wouldn't work
really because I guess it wouldn't quite
work because again now Bishop g5 f4 and
this is not as good because King again
runs away so but but yeah rook to d3 c3
there's even the move B 3 is also clever
but in yeah so I just played c3 because
I just know I need to cover d4 but yeah
rook to d3 is you know it's so c3 takes
takes and Bishop g5 f4 and then if takes
then bishop takes in checkmate yeah it's
a simple game to shows funny funny game
if I if I played that tournament game I
would have definitely calculated it out
but intuition told me in the Blitz game
that there had to be made I mean I saw
all this I saw that him and then when I
got to this position okay I mean I knew
it was gonna be a made when I got to the
position I said okay c3 in there so you
know it's take long to find c3 I wrote
d3 is better